this is where we left off last time and
unceremoniously cut off by Tuesday bail
times
thanks a lot Assemblyman so before we
get to this is the main meal I
appreciate this is qualitatively what if
you than those early examples we looked
at before number one I've third
fractions in their gross number two you
can see I've got variables or pretty
much I should say on both terms which is
very different to those very first
introductory examples where you just had
a one you can almost think of all that
wine it didn't really affect anything
sir my bridge to get into that to help
you out come in a little bit is the
thing about this guy okay now I hope you
recall the way that we did this manually
before where's the notice that you can
build one binomial upon another right
now a plus B or Q maybe you don't know
what that is off the top of your head
but a plus B all squared
that's like what the results that we've
been using for so long they're probably
in your mind right so I can say since I
know what a plus B or swin already is
like so I can very quickly develop the
expansion for the original thing the
cube thing just by doing that trick I
did before taking the trinomial on the
right hand side multiplying everything
by a then doing the same try to do a
multiply everything by B and then you
take the Sun that's all okay so if you
are just catching up with me then here
you can see the first line of M is n
cubed plus 2a squared B plus oops that's
just one plus a B squared you have to do
that there's multiply three by eight I'm
gonna multiply through by B now and just
like before I'm going to sort of push
them down a little bit so I can collect
the like terms more quickly so I'm gonna
get a squared B to a B squared and a big
shoes oh yeah so look all right try to
be one Tramiel to
now it's Tanith now what you observe is
the same pattern of binary coefficients
that pass was triangles numbers that you
saw from last time there's the 1 3 3 1
but what this shows us that the previous
one didn't show us is that you can see
here just like these powers descend from
one of the terms your other power is
ascend from 0 to 1 to 2 to 3
ok so now we're ready let's have a look
at this ok yeah it's 5 that's what the
power is so therefore I'm on the fifth
row of Pascal's triangle I hope you
finished your Pascal's triangle because
it's very useful if you really want to
make it lost you can contacted by the
numbers I think off the top my head are
gonna be 1 5 10 10 5 1 yeah ok cool I
will point out Pascal's triangle not on
the reference sheet but I'll explain why
and today's lesson I will get to in here
how we can use this thing to generate
whatever coefficients we need from
whichever ok so let's have a go
this is 1 5 10 10 5 1 ok so the first
one and I want you get a write it
purposefully for myself he's a 1 I'm not
going to ignore the fact that he thing
and you remember last time like this and
this is a point in this one
what else did an example like this even
though it seems a little more natural
like I have here a is first so a ends up
first over here oh I didn't put the 1 to
the 4 of the first term the reason why
is because why I do is I like to have my
expansions written with the with the
pronumerals is the highest power off the
front so this would be X to the 4 4 X
cubed could someone help ya see 2x
squared or 4x and then the 1 okay
however in this case over here you've
got terms that both have X's in them
okay so therefore I'm going to try to
use this pan here I know miss fine if
you do it in reverse order it's still
the same thing because pass was writing
was symmetrical but he's the way I'm
going to begin I've got one lot of this
to the para 5 for completeness I'm going
to put my own say right that there are
some of these in the number of these
that I have is 0 okay now I put a lot of
effort into that even though there are
some redundant components there so that
I don't forget that there are 3 computes
every single time there's going to be
the binomial coefficient and there's
going to be some number these and some
number of these and they just sort of
balance each other out
you remember I'm now going to go down to
4 and 1 yeah and then you kind of
establish the pattern you do the next
coefficient you bring this down 1 you
bring this up whoops 1 and then you just
sort of go down the other side okay so
I'll just finish this off either quick
for me what you didn't have to do what
which putty talking about like like
whining everything out yeah the short
answer is no the quickest thing that you
can do is you can work out like the
calculator will do these pots for you
and like I said before and I'm going to
putting out here as well
just looking sometimes the less for a
specific term they want you to calculate
and you can get to those quickly however
there's not really like this is in some
ways this is the short step that's the
long way this is the short way right I
used to go straight to the expansion
without any more brackets all the
records are gone let's finish off what's
beyond what's the next
what's an x-squared
okay so let's finish yourself I reckon
we can do all of these only one hit now
because I think the numbers just look at
all of your binary coefficients that's
the only thing contributing a numerical
factor here and then have a look at your
powers carefully so here you've got x2
that I have a look closely we know there
are no other numerical coefficient so
I'm just gonna make that fine
straight away I know I can write a plus
because there are no minus signs sort of
daily even up x2 x squared to the power
of four is going to be X to the 8th but
then you actually do subtract so we can
text to the like so for the next one
you've got the 10 at the front this
would be X to the 6 and then here you're
going to have that's actually X to the
minus 2 isn't it so that leaves you mean
thanks to this form and you kind of set
up for yourself the pattern all right do
you see now what the next one's going to
be it's just going to be an X ok you
almost don't have to think about it
because you can see these powers are
doing something predictable plus 5 lots
of warts
yeah I mean we were provided it without
any negative indices even though I'm
thinking it in negative indices because
I go squared that's a minus four so I
get minus two but since they've provided
to us as a fraction I'm going to provide
it back as a fraction you can see look
I've divided by execute to get from one
term to the next I mean what's the lots
of them now I'll just say yes I did see
Mike it took a long time I'd argue
though it took a lot of this okay so
that's what we're looking at these kinds
of questions about wrapping your head
around what are all the pieces are kind
of able to go to go together that's what
this is all about